હ
[Musique]
autour du monde des hommes bravent les
flots pour convoyer des marchandises sur
des bateaux à la forme souvent inchangé
depuis des
siècles à Madagascar dasiki transporte
du sel à bord d'un boutre un bateau à
voile traditionnel du 19e
siècle entre la Guyane et le Brésil k
manvre sa dans les méandres du fleuve
Oyapok pour acheminer du
ciment deux histoires de marins de
voyage et de
[Musique]
bateau
dans l'océan Indien sur la côte ouest de
Madagascar voici la presquî de Bell
surmer ce village de pêcheurs au bord du
lagon est une terre de bateau
[Musique]
ou plutôt de boutre ces grands bateaux à
voile qui servent au transport de
marchandise
au 18e siècle deux charpentiers breton
viennent s'installer dans ce bout du
monde malgache pour y construire des
bateaux à l'image de leur
goélette 300 ans plus tard les
techniques n'ont pas changé encore
aujourd'hui les chantiers naval
jalonnent la longue
[Musique]
plage marin du village il rejoint son
ami donné sur l'un des chantiers de
construction bonjour bonjour Comment V
les travaux ça avance comme tu veux
ouais ça avance bien très bien même j'en
ai plus pour très
longtemps depuis le temps que je suis
dessus je vais enfin pouvoir naviguer
une fois peint il aura fier
allure iki est né dans une famille de
pêcheurs depuis 10 ans il apprend l'art
de construire des
boutres il y a de façons de vivre la mer
ici soit tu prends la
mer soit tu construis des boutres comme
donné moi je fais partie de ceux qui
pren la
mer mais un peu plus tard quand je serai
vieux j'arrêterai d'aller sur l'eau
j'espère construire des boutres pour mes
[Musique]
enfants
don ce précieux savoirfire il estun des
plus anci charpentiers de marine de
B une trentaine de bout sont déjà entre
ses
mains je de
mé
ce métier il nous fait
vivre travailler sur un boutre c'est
comme travailler dans la
nature c'est une vie que
j'aime avant de disparaître parents nous
ont lgué ce
savoirfaire maintenant c'est à notre
tour de le transmettre comme je fais
aujourd'hui avec mes
apprentis
[Musique]
dasiki habite sur l'une des îles du
lagon de Bell surmer avec sa femme et
leurs se
enfants ce matin il se prépare à partir
pour une expédition de plusieurs jours
le long de la
côte être marin
ça a toujours été le travail de mes
ancêtres soit sur une pirogue soit sur
un
boutre je préfère travailler sur les
boutres ça me fait gagner un peu
d'argent même si ce n'est pas
beaucoup je peux faire vivre ma famille
décemment sinon je passe souvent sur une
pirogue mais je préfère vraiment
naviguer sur un
bout
ce n'est jamais simple quand il part
mais moi aussi je travaille quand il
n'est pas là et je dois le faire pour
nourrir nos
enfants qu mon mari est sur son boutre
je pêche des concombres de mer et des
crabes je ramène pas beaucoup tous les
jours suffit en fait pour nourrir ma
famille c'est comme ça c'est comme ça
qu'on vit tous les deux au village tout
le monde sait qu'on vit comme
ça voilà bon voyage et n'oublie pas de
nous rapporter quelque
chose
[Musique]
[Rires]
à quelques kilomètres du village
s'étendent les salines d'anira les plus
belles de
l'île à Bellot surmer on a toujours
ramassé du sel à la main et construit
des bateaux pour acheminer ce sel vers
les grandes villes du
[Musique]
Nord en fin de journée un étrange balai
se forme autour des boutres les hommes y
chargent les sacs de
selle ces bateaux à voile sont encore
aujourd'hui l'unique moyen de transport
de marchandises sur cette côte
malgache plus d'une centaine de boutres
cabotent toute l'année le long du canal
du Mozambique entre Madagascar et
[Musique]
l'Afrique on transporte le sel en boutre
parce que la route ici est
impraticable et puis le sel c'est très
mauvais pour le moteur des
voitures ça les abîme très
vite et surtout pour transporter des
grosses quantités de sel en peu de
voyage le boutre est idéal en un seul
voyage on peut transporter jusqu'à 50
tonn chargement alors c'est sûr ici les
camions c'est beaucoup moins
efficace ce soir le bateau de dasiki
part avec 25 tonnes de sel cap sur
mentirano à 300 km plus au
nord le sel c'est quelque chose de très
précieux ici alors il faut faire très
attention à notre
chargement en plus ce sel n'est pas à
nous il faut l'acheminer en bon état à
son
destinataire
on essaie de bien faire notre travail
pour que les gens continuent à nous
faire confiance si on perdait les 25
tonnes de sel que nous transportons dans
notre cale on ne pourrait pas les
rembourser ça représente une
fortune alors on demande la bénédiction
de Dieu pour arriver à bon
[Musique]
port
avec embar àord a le bien arrivé un
boutre de 14 m de
long les voilà partis pour plusieurs
jours de voyage au gré du
[Musique]
vent de l'autre côté du globe à plus de
10000 km de
Madagascar d'autres marchandises
naviguent au fil de
l'eau au milieu de la forêt amazonienne
coule un fleuve
l'oyapo un cours d'eau qui serpente sur
plus de 400 km et sépare la Guyane
française du Brésil avant de se jeter
dans l'océan
[Musique]
Atlantique ici le fleuve est roi et
attire toute la vie sur ses
flots entre les
r le bateau est l'unique moyen de
[Musique]
transport du côté brésilien oyapoc est
l'une des plus grandes villes qui bordde
le
[Musique]
fleuve bon
CIA K
vyap et comme beaucoup d'hommes ici il
est
piroguier
ça fait 32 ou 33 ans que je fais ce
métier j'ai commencé à être pirogier
tout jeune à l'âge de 17
ans ce matin il quit la ville pour une
nouvelle mission de 3 jours sur le
fleuve
ici on transporte de tout du ciment des
câbles du coffrage tout ce qu'on nous
demande de transporter on peut le
faire on peut charger jusqu'à 3 tonnes
sur une
pirogue à partir d'ici il n'y a plus de
route alors pour transporter tout le
matériel il n'y a que le
fleuve mais c'est bien ça donne du
travail à beaucoup de gens ici ça fait
vivre du
monde on est dans un endroit isolé c'est
difficile de
survivre alors on apprend le métier de
pirier comme qui une centaine de pirogu
F les e DEAP tous les
[Musique]
jour je suis né et j'ai grandi
ici et quand on est du coin on connait
déjà le fleuve depuis tout petit on est
fait pour vivre sur ces
[Musique]
rives moi j'ai appris à Man une pirogue
ça m'a plu et ça me plaît encore
[Musique]
aujourd'hui j'ai déjà travaillé sur des
cargots mais la pirogue c'est vraiment
ce que je
préfère
pour cette mission kya transporte de
tonnes de ciment sur sa
pirogue un précieux chargement qu'il
doit mener à Bonport jusqu'à Camopi la
ville la plus en amont du
fleuve un voyage de plus de 100 km sur
l'yapoc un cours d'eau aux fausses
allures de grand
calme je soulève le moteur pour mieux
diriger la pirogue car le niveau d'eau
est bas on est en saison
[Musique]
je connais bien le fleuve chaque
rocher parfois le moteur tape une pierre
mais ce n'est pas grave de toute façon
il n a pas d'autrees
passage avec des charges légères les
voyages sont moins
compliqués mais comme aujourd'hui quand
on a du ciment ou des Bries par
exemple plus lourde et c'est beaucoup
plus
inquiétant il faut vraiment redoubler
[Musique]
l'attention il faut juste tourner un
peu de l'autre côté pas
encore juste en
face pour l'aider RER les dangers du
fleuve travaille AC
un aide piroguier que l'on appelle ici
un
tariste j'ai besoin de lui pour
surveiller l'avant de la
pirogue il est là pour éviter les
rochers il utilise sa rame pour
m'aider lorsque le niveau du fleuve est
bas si on traverse un rapide et si je
ralentis il va prendre la rame pour
m'aider à me
diriger per le contrôle de la pirogue le
moteur à lui seul ne peut pas garder le
câ de la pirogue donc il est très
important le tacariste c'est un travail
d'équipe il faut être de dans une
pirogue comme
[Musique]
çaine a presque la même connaissance du
fleuve que
moi sans son aide surtout en été quand
le fleuve est bas comme ça je ne
pourrais vraiment pas conduire la
pirogue tout seul jusqu'à camopie
[Musique]
il reste au pirogier de jours de voyage
pour atteindre
Camopi le jour se lève sur le canal du
Mozambique entre la côte Est Africaine
et
Madagascar premier jour de voyage pour
dasiki et son
équipage le vent du sud souffle fort ils
ont déjà parcouru plus de 90
km sans moteur le boutre ne peut compter
que sur le vent pour
avancer à bord chacun connaî sa
partition pour faire filer le Todisoa
toute voile
dehorsiki est le second capitaine
je suis sur la mer depuis que j'ai 14
ans mes aés m'em déjà pêcher plonger et
bien sûr naviguer sur les
boutres
il y a beaucoup de métiers que je
pourrais faire qui pourra me plaire et
dont je ne pourrais pas me
ler mais celui être
marin être sur
l'eau c'est le métier que les dieux
m'ont
destiné un vrai
cadeau
vasy doucement de déchirer la voile F
lui est le capitaine du navire c'est bon
arriv c'est aussi un constructeur de
bateau traditionnel le tooa est son 20è
boutre cui c'est mon dernier
boutre je l' constr pour
moi bébé après celui-là
j'arrête je commence à
fatiguer on reconnait un boutre parce
qu'il est toujours en
bois et puis la forme de la coque est
particulière aussi l'avant et l'arrière
se ressemblent
beaucoup les boutr ont aussi des m très
haut
hélène est la femme du
capitaine je suis en train de préparer
du
tabaki c'est de l'écorce de tamarinier
qui me sert à me protéger du
soleil c'est une sorte de masque pour le
visage
c'est ce qui nous rend belle nous les
femmes donc le matin on se lève on
prépare notre tabi on fait notre
toilette d'abord pu on applique le
Tab je fais ça pour garder le te
clair car avec le soleil et le
salé ma pe sabî très
vite même sur le bateau je prends
toujours le temps de prendre soin de moi
et je le fais très tôt le matin parce
que si je n'en mets pas pendant 2 jours
je le vois tout de suite ma peau noirci
et je n'aime pas ça
elle est aussi la cuisinière du
[Musique]
todoa attention il
s'échappe
[Musique]
il y a des choses qu'on ne peut pas
apporter sur un
bateau le poulet le porc et les pois
bombar par exemple c'est interdit sur un
bateau ça porte
malheur ce midi je prépare du canard
je vais d'abord le ramollir avec l'eau
le faire bouillir pour avoir du jus et
une fois bien cuit je vais faire une
sauce avec de l'huile des tomates
assortiment d'oignon de gingembre et
d'ail
ce sont mes parents qui m'ont appris à
[Musique]
cuisiner comme je savais que j'allais me
marier un
jour il fallait que je sache
cuisiner j'ai commencé à m'entraîner
avec un peu de
riz pour les plats aussi j'ai appris
avec des petites
quantités c'est comme ça que j'ai appris
cette recette au canard par
exemple
[Applaudissements]
ce qui me plaît quand je suis en mer
c'est d'être loin des tracat de la ville
respirer l'air marin ça me fait vraiment
du
bien je préfère largement naviguerre sur
terre rester au village c'est pas bon
pour ma
santé en plus c'est le métier de mes
parents vraiment fier de prendre le
[Musique]
relais après une première journée de
vent et de soleil le boutre maintient
son cap et file droit sur
[Musique]
mentirano
retour sur le
fleuveapoc une heure après leur départ K
et son tariste s'apprêt à attaquer la
partie la plus dangereuse du fleuve les
saut de
Maripa une succession de dénivl rocheux
qui en saison sèche s'étendent sur
plusieurs
kilomètres
la difficulté majeure remonter ses rapid
avec une pirogue ultra chargée à
contrecourant sur
l'AP RAR sont ceux qui comme qui peuvent
relever ce
défi ici on est dans une partie du fleu
très dangereuse l'eau est vraiment très
basse en ce moment et il y a beaucoup de
rapide il faut faire très attention pour
ne pas abîmer la
[Musique]
pirogue
c'est le bouchon de vidange je le ferme
pour passer les
rapidesand accélère l'au est à
l'intérieur de la pirogue svacue par le
trou mais quand on réd la vitesse il
faut mettre le
bouchon la
p
ici commence les
[Musique]
rapides tiine passe derrière le
rocher une entente parfaite et
primordiale entre le pyoguier et son
tariste
[Musique]
je fais signe avec le moteur et là il
sait déjà quoi
faire rien qu'au bruit du moteur il se
retourne et il
sait il pr la R et je lui dis de tourner
à droite ou à
gauche on n pas besoin de
parler
[Musique]
soisal l'adrénaline est à son
maximum dans un rapide on ne peut pas
s'arrêter
regard le fleuve ou regard sa
marchandise souvent les gens se
demandement il
fa faut pas se poser de
question il faut y aller et réussir à
[Musique]
traverser chaque année après la saison
des pluies le lit du fleuve
change
k ont beau connaître l'AP parur il reste
vigilant pour ne pas commettre une faute
de parcours et renverser la précieuse
[Musique]
marchandise tout
dro
la pirogue vient de heurter un
rocher arrêtetoi
ici en fait P un peu par
[Musique]
làau
ch échoué et on a dû la pousser et
maintenant on fait
demitour blo moteur pour tourner ici en
suivant le cours du
fleuve
chanceis
après 45 minutes d'effort intense les
deux hommes sortent enfin de la zone
dangereuse des saut de
Maripa un peu plus loin vers le sud le
fleuve s'élargi
ENF ici les eyap sont généreuses et
attirent les pêcheurs des
environs bonjour ça va bonjour la pêche
bonne ça
va je peux voir ce que vous avez pêché
ouai bien sûr vous montrez votre
pêche voilà et vous allez rester ici un
peu oui la marée est en train de monter
non ça va aller allez je vais te prendre
des
poissons voilà bon merci bonne pêche
[Musique]
merci pchees pche les gens des villages
aux alentours
pêche et ensuite ils vendent des
poissons à Saint-Georges ou à
oyap pour pouvoir acheter du riz des
haricots ou du
poulet les gens du coin survivent
vraiment grâce au
[Musique]
poissons la nuit tombe sur
l'yapoc la navigation est devenue
dangereuse voyons si notre construction
est encore debout pour pouvoir passer la
nuit
ici Kia et son aide s'arrêtent dans un
endroit bien connu des
pyoguiers sur les rives de
pas d'hôtel le BiVO et de
rigueur dans la soirée un autre piroguer
les rejoint c'est très agréable
fleu la belle
étoile en ville il fait trop
chaud ici c'est
super on respire l'air
purure pas de
télé a pas de portable qui va
sonner pour nous
déranger ici on est tranquille on pense
à
rien je partirai pas d'ici faut vraiment
qu'on m'y oblige ou alors je tue
quelqu'un et on m'expulse mais sinon
jamais je partirai
d'ici ici on ouvre une boîte de conserve
un sac de farine de manioc on mange on
dort
tôt le fleuve nous aide à nous reposer à
nous vider la
tête il nous protège et nous porte
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chance
au matin du 3e jour le boutre de dasiki
est stoppé dans sa
[Musique]
course là il y a pas de vent du
tout le vent est
tombé on attend au mouillage qu'il se
lève il y a rien d'autre à faire
pour la livraison du sel propriétaire
conna les alé de la mer donc il
attendra c'est ça être marin ce n'est
pas nous qui commandons le vent c'est
Dieu il fait comme il
veut
[Musique]
je prépare l'aiguille et le fil pour
pouvoir recoudre cette voile
[Musique]
elle s'est
déchiré elle est
vieille je la recou vite fait pour
qu'elle se tende bien quand on va
[Musique]
repartir c'est bien les moments de calme
comme ça faire ce genre de
[Musique]
chose ah d' on VO le vent commence à
souffler allez on y va les
gars après une demi-journée sans un brin
d'air le vent du sud se remet enfin à
souffler l'équipage s'active pour tenter
de rattraper le temps
perdu
[Musique]
on est toujours dans la même zone depuis
un moment tu le crois
ça si on avait déjà passé en tondrolo on
aurait pu être là-bas ce
soir on même pas
passé si on avavance pas on sera en mer
encore pendant un bon bout de
temps garde le cap plus à l'ouest
voilà pour l'instant ce n'est pas trop
dur mais quand le vent souffle l'astuce
c'est la corde avec ce système on évite
de se fatiguer le
bras là là
[Musique]
j'arrive à me diriger parce que le
capitaine est
là il m'indique le chemin et le cap
prendre à force de suivre ses conseils
je commence à bien connaître le
chemin mais il faut être concentré pour
avancer tout
droiti surveiller la dan des voiles pour
pas qu' soitop
tend
c'est vrai que la mer c'est toute notre
vie mais je préfère travailler à bord
des boutres parce que finalement c'est
beaucoup plus simple que la pêche pour
gagner ma
vie
[Musique]
il pèse lourd ce ton et c'est de la
super
qualité ça va être vrai
régale cô le filet pour plus tard non
j'ai pas
envie
l'équipage a déjà un jour de retard sur
la livraison le capitaine décide alors
de naviguer de
nuit sur un boutre il n'y a aucun
instrument de
pilotage la navigation se fait à vue
[Musique]
la nuit pour continuer à naviguer on
suit les
étoiles on obser le position pour sair
où est le Nord O est le
sud rien
àreit
ancêtres nous ont bienmis sair on a
dans
[Musique]
c'est une chanson qui vient de chez
moi c'est une chanson
traditionnelle on la chante sur les
bateaux qui navig le long de la
côte mais maintenant on peut les chanter
aussi sur terre
ce sont des chansons qui racontent des
histoires de
[Musique]
marin
si S
hom an
[Musique]
ni
5h30 du matin sur
leapoc la brume est à peine
levé mais les pirers sont déjà à pied
[Musique]
d'vrez on boit un jus et on continue le
voyage
vers
si tout se passe bien il nous faut 2
heur pour aller jusqu'à Camopi sans
s'arrêter sans s'arrêter
[Musique]
oui dans ce coin reculé de l'Amazonie le
fleuve est la seule route à travers la
[Musique]
forêt pour faire vivre ces villages
isolés la pirogue est essentielle
[Musique]
essentiel pour les grands et les petits
les 150 enfants des villages alentour
prennent la pirogue comme d'autres
prennent le bus pour aller à
[Musique]
l'école sur l'yap tous les pirers se
connaissent
[Musique]
après de jours de voyage éprouvant K et
per arrivent enfin à Camopi pour livrer
leur de tonne de
ciment
[Musique]
mon but c'était que le chargement arrive
en un seul morceau dans les mains du
propriétaire là maintenant j'ai la
conscience
tranquille encore un voyage qui se
termine demain
avant de repartir les piroguier s'arrête
chez
Jacqueline c'est le dernier restaurant
sur le fleuve avant le prochain village
saint-georg à de jours de voyage
d'ici salqu j'ai très faim qu'est-ce
qu'il y a à
manger du poisson
grillé c'est le relais routier de
les gens du coin ouvrent leur cantine
sur la rive c'est une bonne source de
revenu pour
eux les clients viennent des deux côtés
du fleuve français et
brésilien donc les gens comme Jacqueline
dépendent beaucoup des
pirogers c'est compliqué pour moi de
sortir d'aller en ville quand j'ai
besoin de quelque chose je demande à un
P de
l'aorter dès qu'on veut se déplacer il
faut traverser les rochers et les
rapides il faut payer pour le
transport charger la Pirog pour
traverser les rapides tout ça me coûte
très cher c'est compliqué donc je
préfère rester
[Musique]
ici
ici tout se passe au bord du
fleuve on lave le linge la vaisselle on
prend une douche on fait vraiment tout
au bord du
fleuve mais pour boire de l'eau il faut
aller au pu on ne boit pas l'eau du
fleuve surtout
pas
[Musique]
c'est particulier de vivre ici c'est
très beau c'est très
Tran
magnif a terminé sa
mission il est temps maintenant de
redescendre le fleuve
[Musique]
un voyage de plus de 12h attend les deux
piroguiers pour enfin rentrer chez
[Musique]
eux pour dasiki à Madagascar c'est
presque la fin du
voyage
avant d'arriver à mentirano leur
destination finale ils font escale aux
îles
baren des confetties de sable posé sur
l'océan
Indien des îles quasiment inhabitées à
l'exception de quelques Hut de
roseau ici vivent les vais une
communauté de pêcheurs nomades
l'équipage vient leur livrer tris sacs
de sel indispensable pour la
conservation de leur
[Musique]
poissons pas facile il y a beaucoup de
houles pourra pas costé le bateau va
rester ici à mouiller à 200
m et on va prendre la pirogue pour y
aller Metz pas comme
çaut fa descendre
et l'utre B va
suiv voilà mets la verticale tiens bien
vas-y avance un tout petit peu voilà on
mettra le second derrière allez
ou
voilà hlène la femme du capitaine
profite de cette livraison pour rendre
visite à sa
familleut mon
[Musique]
chéri
sa cousine et vit sur
nosimarwantali la plus grande des îles
de
l'archipel un d' peine 2 km car où s'est
installé une centaine de
vais ce peuple de pêcheur disséminé sur
toute la partie ouest de
[Musique]
Madagascar
autrefois nomade sous la pression de la
vie moderne ces hommes de la mer se sont
aujourd'hui presque tous
[Musique]
sédentarisés ils vont quand même sur la
côte de temps en temps surtout quand il
n'ont plus rien à manger ou plus d'
douce ce sont vraiment les seuls moments
où il quitent
l'île ou si vraiment il y a un problème
sinon il reste
là alors ici c'est la
chambre ici c'est la
cuisine et là on entrepose tous les
poissons qu'on aura
séché ces pêcheurs exceptionnels ne
vivent que des ressources de la
mer il y a plein d'autres poisson qu'il
faut ressaler
là tu es vraiment arrivé à temps avec
les sacs on commen à manquer de
sel on met du sel sur les poissons pour
les
conserver le sel ça leurvite de pourir
et ça les fait sécher plus
vite c'est un peu comme la glace chez
vous on le met dans le bac pendant 2
jours puis à sécher pendant 3 jours on
les lave bien comme ça et après on les
fait
sécher quand on stock le poisson dans
notre magasin et bien on peut le garder
jusqu'à de ou 3 mois sans problème là ce
sont des
rais là c'est du
requin celui-là je ne sais
pas ça c'est du poisson
chat ça aussi ça c'est du
requin et c'est à nouveau du poisson
[Musique]
chat
avec ce vent favorable m Tyrano n'est
plus qu'à 3 heur de
[Musique]
navigation pour le déchargement on verra
ça une fois rentrer au
port on n pas encore
arrivé ma préoccupation pour l'instant
c'est de rentrer dans la passe
[Musique]
ça y est on y est presque je vois déjà
la
[Musique]
ville mais un dernier obstacle attend
les marins une forte houle se lève et
oblige à mouiller au large une dernière
fois c'est menano qu'on voit
là-bas je suis content d'être arrivé
d'avoir fait ce long
chemin je suis
[Musique]
soulagé plus qu'une nuit d'attente pour
les marins du
todoa demain matin ils arriveront à
[Musique]
destination alors que le voyage de
dasiki se termine à Madagascar en Guyane
qui a le pyoguier est à nouveau en
mission sur son
fleuve il navigue tout au nord cette
fois-ci vers wanarie à l'embouchure de
l'Oyapoc là où les eaux du fleuve se
confondent avec cell de
l'océan pour moi ça n'a jamais été
difficile j'aime mon
travail le matin quand je me lève je
suis déjà
[Musique]
motivé
je ne pourrais pas aller vivre dans une
ville j'aime cet endroit j'aime aller
sur l'eau aller pêcher aller sur les
rapides sauter dans l'eau pêcher du
poisson puis le faire griller au bord du
fleuve dans une ville on ne peut pas
faire tout
[Musique]
ça
j'aime ce
fleuve grâce à lui grâce rap je ma
famille en faisant le travail que
j'aime je mourir
ici terminer ma
vie dans le fleu bien sûr mais chez
moi c'est
bien
sur un fleuve ou sur la mer ces routiers
des flots vont continuer inlassablement
à faire vivre leurs bateaux qui ont
traversé les
[Musique]
temps
ye